[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sure well relief crunch just going here
mama
clearly they've never been on camera
before there's so much more upside than
downside in taking risk at a young age
it's just practical it's practical to go
high-risk high-reward
in your teens and twenties it's just
like practical and I and I think the
reason people don't is they love their
parents or grandparents or somebody in
their life is they don't want to
disappoint by doing the thing that seems
crazy to that elder and you know I don't
want to sit on a pedestal and say you
know do do that I understand what's
stopping them I just want to challenge
people to recognize that regret is very
scary sighs thank you so much for coming
have you guys have a break me thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and what ends up happening is you're
protecting your parents feelings in your
20s by doing the thing you want them to
do so how advanced it is in a
relationship in your forties fifties and
sixties in your parents says less
healthy because you start blaming them
for not taking those jumps and so I feel
like you can fight with your parents now
or later and I just think it works out
much better in the upfront question oh
man clap it off on this wonderful
interview you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering back we bought in
20 some real wine Jordan Jordan can you
bring real wine I'm like freaking out
all this [ __ ] rose I had been
drinking like this looks real probably
all free musically this way for yourself
as well knowing a little bit about all
the waiting it's like so much
when the market comes to you remember
having conversations with humans about
like followers and that you know like to
stop right like it's never it's only the
best when you come here
and I like let it come to you and I
think that really has like he was not
wavering or conforming for like adjust
right he's are doing his job he's doing
his thing and he'll just basically
creates the world to come to it and do I
[ __ ] love this African plain and by
instead of like okay let me go make
diseases because that's up you know long
game yeah
we are very very fortunate to have one
of my favorite wine people
and he's like know how I feel about AD
people I hate wine people more so to
penetrate that is very difficult but in
this intimate setting will taste will
jam they'll be funded let's take our
wine son trout he's going to try to act
cool
others will act humble which we
appreciate for like 30 years the last 30
years up until 7 to 10 years ago the
wine business in America the computer
was that cared about wine not like you
know just bought it like - just because
I loved wine but they dress right $8
while I cared enough about it it was
completely dictated by the Wine
Spectator and Robert Wagner and I mean
completely - voices dictation and they
didn't support those a and the truth is
most people just believe that you
graduated to red wine is the real thing
white wines the entry and Rose a was
White Zinfandel what a lot of you didn't
live through if you're young enough but
if you go way back what you know White
Zinfandel in the 80s and 90s was sweet
pink wine four bucks five bucks a bottle
and it was sewn up so rosy and America
got killed because white simba del was
uniquely American in the late seventies
early eighties early nineties yeah so
the white the white
the white does white zinfandel craze in
America killed the Rose a market for
wash mode a now on a pedestal leaded
into the u.s. is bonkers to me to your
point whether it was Instagram it was
bloggers it was other voices that
finally were able to penetrate and
listen if you ask me my proudest part of
my chapter in the wine business
it was that Wine Library TV will always
be synonymous as one of those first
things the wouldn't so many historian
here wine lemon PD was one of the first
things to penetrate those two big
pillars and up and create another voice
which then inspired all the some the
blog and video blog and then Instagram
is social and now every sommelier every
personality there's just democratization
all right I'm excited about tonight
Jordan Jordan how are you okay I'll be
honest I got a call early different
curveball after me brunch
that's like at a panel packed me dinner
and a pit thing act neatly late with DJs
and in the middle vaynermedia b2b Steve
what are you - chief creative officer
wedding - in five four seconds
Jordan how do you how do the wine
tasting the wine tasting there's a must
buy a fun way you think a little time
thank you
okay send me Ruby
what have you accomplished again growing
17 member board in the were they are a
wide confidence have you done anything
for enough tip here just film for some
people there's God's eye scary beating
three we didn't do crap I'm working on
your black coffee all the time black
coffee for you Tom bill you I got some
Diddy on the screen your specfically
next productive McCann
[Music]
nobody remembers the losses
and the reason I say nobody remembers
losses everybody's playing to the
audience and that audience maybe your
mom one person and everybody plays for
different things
hi I think that nobody remembers the
loss I mean guys nobody remembers the
losses no but guys Shaquille O'Neal is
should Sam the first thing you think you
know what the real I can't graduate
challenge that because it's people you
hit a certain skit like I know righty I
bet you can all named LeBron losses
nobody can remember its losses time ever
I know I mean I lost it Dirk in 2006 you
know Jordan fauces power none you're
wrong no no and my fire no no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's the thing
Jordan Jordan I'm you're you're young
how old are you 30 nobody remembers the
losses on 40 what was that 32 games a
twin season in a row now would even that
nobody nobody remembers the losses
Michael Jordan when I was in a prime of
my sportsmanship junior high in high
school this is real Michael Jordan this
is going to blow your face off a loser
can't get over to hump you know why
couldn't beat the piston couldn't beat
them couldn't be the Celtics I live the
life I live it's crazy I look right
nobody and I promise you what it's done
LeBron and eight straight finals and yes
you know what you're gonna say LeBron
played for 29 Hall of Famers Michael
Jordan played three guys like nobody
remembers is all awesome luckily I die I
don't prove my point so I'm happy
because he was ultimately that great my
thing is this more in another another
way to say it another way to answer a
question
it all ends up the right way at the end
if you were great enough because
whatever your Excuse is going to be to
why it didn't happen the way was
supposed to me it means you [ __ ] up
like at the end of a it is what it is
right like like like this is very
different you rely on so many people why
boxing you know fault like
unbusinesslike like if I'm as good if I
think I am it's all going to play out
and if it's not it was lying not caring
enough about money
it was my it was my getting too much on
the long-term it was it was it was
things that like I'll know what they
were that stopped me I'm named two of
them right now that would stop me from
being on the place where I want to be
and I'm okay with that clearly because
I'm still betting on it but my big thing
is it ends up the way it's supposed to
be so like we are like I feel so bad for
everybody here oh you're gonna show me
they interacts so proud of you can wanna
be a searing wait Hannah be AB come up
with everything I'm like not every night
others dog my head all the song may go
notice why uncle
[Music]
too many doesn't my mother gets a good
night so why did you write it I don't
need no help I don't anything isn't
always a time man killing the demon I
gotta go back anybody they heard about
it they know when they kidding me bit in
it nobody get in a bit and I get in my
way get this I like to whatever was
because I could go put you on blast
people be mad at me cuz there's no color
than bag of lessons head us away what
are you're trying to act like they've
been busting we're really the bus the
bus in a mug nobody ever made me me
rockin is kind of like talking to me now
right now guys and now like that
Muhammad Ali comment I said about like
what was he thinking than the fight up
it's really funny is like I need more of
that from you and like usually I don't
like the listen of the rock but he's not
wrong like that one of the things that I
have to just continue to do is we try to
get better and like I need to try harder
you know it's so funny I don't complain
you know and I don't like talking about
[ __ ] until I have it fully formulated
believe it or not wear as much as I run
my mouth and so the insight is for me to
talk about what I'm thinking there's
only two things I'm thinking about
things that are [ __ ] up and thus since
I don't want to complain I've nothing to
say to you and things that I'm thinking
about like house it's all playing out it
what's actually happening here like the
strategy but because they're 53% in 41%
72 percent clear thoughts I don't share
them I think a lot of the other pun in a
lot of the other people out there talk
about [ __ ] that they don't understand
just the pond and Britney get back there
see rock
I'm allowed to be creative ability
anyway but I think a lot of other people
talked she had run their [ __ ] mouth
when it will have complete salt you know
and so I'm in for sharing the more I'm
into sharing more relaxed throughout I
mean the sharing more I need to figure
out what I'm comfortable with because we
all have comfort zones and things that
were not comfortable with and I don't
like to run my mouth and I don't like to
be clean and and I will challenge myself
to continue to think about keeping you
the process here's what I'm thinking I'm
going to [ __ ] dominate like it's
[ __ ] over if people don't get it that
I'm playing in 2027 you know like I will
show you some rapper goes a rapper I'd
be perfect because because it's like in
a song format I could be like I'm on 27
you're stuck in 17 you know like you
know like that you know I could do that
thing I don't like for all the pound
chest thing like I don't feel
comfortable like I need to become a
rapper because because that culture that
vibe that genre of communication there's
a there's a good way to brag to give you
an insight here's my insight like I have
this figured out I'm going to outwork
you I'm going to out real everyone of
you I'm gonna how will you I'm going to
out will you oh by the way I'm smart and
strategic I understand what the [ __ ] is
going on
I know when their shifts in culture a
great intuition a consumer behavior I
understand voice arbitrage already
that's why I'm trying to talk about it
now I'm going to win that game gonna win
the [ __ ] podcast game I'm going to
win the [ __ ] the Lexus scale game I'm
gonna [ __ ] win that like that's
what's going on I'm going to win and the
other thing that's going through my mind
is you ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
Gary B you [ __ ] music you're going to
win she's not going [ __ ] if you believe
for one second that you're going to win
that's all from Alliance Sirach I'll try
better whoa wish I could talk to be
hugging me telling you Tony distress
down everything gonna be good so just
focus on being the best down
nevertheless I won't ever get this and I
worked and I know on the bed now looking
around and is looking like everyone busy
they wanna hit it now you people the
reason I doubted me I thought that I
wouldn't be good enough whenever they
are bitching having me I wish you not
always a knew herself